the man accused of killing a bicyclist
in a dui crash late friday night
appeared in court this morning 26 year
old raymond perez hernandez is charged
in this case the crash happened near las
vegas boulevard and pecos where 41 year
old a.b mendables was riding his bike
madison kimbrough is there tonight live
with the message from that victim's
grieving family madison
yes this tragedy happened right by the
tire shop you can see behind me and you
can actually still see the marks here on
the road where the crash happened
a father brother and son 41 year old a.b
mendiples was killed while riding his
bike on his way to meet a friend friday
night metro police say a 2007 chevy
cobalt was going north on las vegas
boulevard when the suspect drove into
the sidewalk hitting and killing a.b
tonight his family is distraught saying
this type of tragedy happens too often
across the valley i'm tired of hearing
on the news every day it's somebody
people are so reckless
i think we need stricter laws
finding out this guy's charges it's not
vehicular manslaughter or anything like
that it's like you took an innocent life
that phone call is just the worst ever
to get as for the driver 26 year old
raymond perez hernandez he was taken to
the hospital with minor injuries and is
now in custody booked into the clark
county detention center for dui related
charges
this bicyclist's death marks the
70-second deadly crash in metro
jurisdiction this year if you would like
to help out abey's family with funeral
expenses they have a gofundme page we
have that link up on our website
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now